à l'arrivée des négociateurs russes et
craignait en turquie les attentes
n'étaient pourtant pas très élevé
le monde entier attend de bonnes
nouvelles de votre part a déclaré le
président turc après quatre heures de
discussions une percée inattendue
les négociateurs ukrainiens ont proposé
que le pays devienne neutre sans
présence militaire étrangère sur son
territoire en échange un accord
international ferai en sorte que des
pays comme les etats unis la france
israël la turquie ou même le canada
serait garant de la sécurité de
l'ukraine 76 une entente inspirée de
l'otan avec une clause de protection
mutuelle l'ukraine réclame aussi la paix
sur l'ensemble de son territoire et que
la proposition soit soumise à un
référendum kiev suggère aussi une
période de consultation de 15 ans sur le
statut de la crim est annexée
illégalement par la russie en 2014
les négociateurs russes évoquent des
pourparlers constructifs la proposition
sera soumise à vladimir poutine et pour
favoriser le dialogue la russie propose
un apaisement
de réduire radicalement les activités
militaires de la russie dans les régions
de kiev de tchernia
le chef de la diplomatie turque parle
des progrès les plus importants depuis
le début des pourparlers mais sur le
terrain les obstacles demeurent nombreux
la france n'a pas réussi à convaincre de
la dîmière poutine d'accepter une
opération d'évacuation dans la ville de
mario paul où sont coincés 160 mille
civils
la ville est pilonnée sans cesse depuis
la fin février tant
que les troupes russes font à marioupol
est un crime contre l'humanité a déclaré
le président ukrainien devant des
parlementaires danois ou si washington
et londres restent prudents face aux
promesses d'accalmie de la russie au
delà des paroles les occidentaux
attendent de voir quelles seront les
actions des militaires russes sur le
terrain cette avancée diplomatique est
un point de départ mais les tractations
pourraient durer des années ici louis
blouin radio-canada paris